a Matt have you seen Josh anywhere we're
supposed to shoot in like five minutes
no why the hell would you leave me a
note miles while I am not actually dead
I have gone on Pat leave so if you
wouldn't mind taking care of the show
while I'm gone I'd appreciate it
here's the script for this episode PS
don't [__] it up
in real life you don't get to choose
your own name Thurman Merman
yeah sure when you're an adult you can
go and legally change it but by then
you've already spent most of your
existence being called something but
thanks to the internet and video games
we're all given a second chance I used
to be a sneaky Castro wonderful and then
right snipped my balls off remove the
Castro and obtuse sneaky the opportunity
to fully rebrand the power to create an
alter-ego that can express our identity
and tell the rest of the world what we
are all about the doctors been preparing
himself
for his real entrance into the online
gaming community I've got to make sure
the power stays on but let's be honest
that doesn't mean we're all gonna choose
wisely
boring calendar oh my god the voice is a
beef right there the gamertag also known
as an alias handle or nickname is a
staple of eSports and has become a
defining trademark for some of its
biggest stars and for as long as we've
had to log into something they've been a
necessary element to the formation of
our online identity but how have naming
conventions developed over the last 20
or so years well one of the earliest
trends we can actually point to is elite
speak short for elite speak league is a
type of computer language that was first
used by hackers and online gamers to
kind of covertly communicate with one
another leap developed as a way to
encode text by substituting numbers in
place of letters whether this was to
avoid moderation or the FBI is not
totally clear but Leafs presence thrived
during the early internet and it wasn't
long before it found its way into
people's gaming handles one three three
seven gamers most they're like a dick
and face together with a little bit of
heroin in the middle perhaps the most
enjoyable thing about using lead back
then was that it confused and often
alarmed the [__] out of people who
weren't so internet savvy you know what
in AI f OC means or how about this or
especially this well teenagers know what
all this means
they sure do it's part of a complicated
and it's forsworn potentially dangerous
code designed to keep parents in the
dark all my friends ep's lead speak i
can see about why parents will be
worried because
it could it can lead to danger the
lexicon of lead included widely used
terms like pone woot and of course new
but it also produced suffixes like or
often tacked on the words like hacks
this sort of naming convention was cool
for a while but eventually became cliche
and seen as obnoxious when overdone
wheat was particularly popular in
counter-strike and remains prevalent in
a minimalist sense today which we can
see with players like device simple
noting forest and config among others
route but it's convict just goes
absolutely huge also fans of simplicity
Korean gamers have taken to the trend of
adopting single English words as handles
this tradition goes as far back as some
of the earliest competitive gaming in
Korea when Starcraft pros picked cool
sounding English words as their alias
like yellow Savior and boxer
[Applause]
while it might seem weird that these
Korean players who spoke very little
English would choose non Korean words
for usernames it actually makes a lot of
sense the Roman alphabet has more
potential for global recognition than
the Korean Hangul characters of course
there are examples of iconic players
like Jae dong and Ryu Jae Hong who chose
to go with non-english handles there's a
trend of Korean
eSports athletes sporting English
usernames remains pervasive in the
League of Legends and overwatch
definitely did not see that coming -
neither did we
what a play from bird rings back in the
early days of competitive Counter Strike
on top of the three-letter nicknames
that were popular in the French and
Brazilian scenes one of the most
annoying trends and gamer tags emerged
camelcase
[Music]
[Applause]
not only does this aggravating style
make it a pain in the ass to read
players names
it rarely looks good and let me tell you
something from a production standpoint
nothing is more infuriating than having
to react sport an entire story of video
because you put the wrong letter
capitalised in a stupid camelcase name
I'm looking at you get right camelcase
is wrong you're gonna make me react
sport for this we have to get it right
how about get [__] but that's not the
only grading trend we've seen with gamer
tags over the years so I had the bright
idea I was like you know what [__] it
I'm just gonna take a line this persona
of being a [__] clown being a joke so
guess what the [__] I made my gamertag I
made myself LX mr. Pfister and as online
gaming continues to grow so too has the
boldness of edge lords everywhere the
ability to hide behind an anonymous
username has given rise to profane or
gross handles simply for the sake of
provoking reactions boomer 69 so if you
want a better nickname what should you
do well an in-joke or a reference is
usually pretty cool for example ice
tea's user name is Lord 187 X the Lord
and X are a bit edgy for sure but the
187 refers to the section of the
California Penal Code that deals with
murder way to wrong color your life
could end homicide my favorite binge
colors another option while plain is
using some variation of your actual name
like Kenny s or Henry G or Gibson
three time lcx play baby
and maybe you could even use your tag as
a tribute to someone you idolize like
the London Spitfires Bergeron whose
handle references see so well so you
shut that big cigar is immense all
what's it I get this we go looking for
that shot is usually pretty accurate but
the shippers Lulay hi Maggie to do total
to daru how much buzz Oh Paul did ah the
little [__] is your poverty getting lost
but in eSports there is actually a
faction of people out there who want to
get rid of gamer tags entirely the
arguments vary but the idea is that as
these sports grow it would make more
sense to just refer to people's actual
names and this point of view does have
some merit as there are handles out
there that aren't exactly flattering the
arrows gonna connect on my nuts
for example kevin ppmd manny one of the
five gods of smash bros melee was
previously known as weak [__] from dr.
Petrie that's right
he was dr. PP real like a man on fire
even though the story behind the handle
might be kind of funny you can see why
it's problematic in an eSports
environment hi I'm Jake also known as
sir action slacks but regrettably I
should have been colonel quit that was
number two so ah
over the last decade competitive gaming
has fought for mainstream acceptance and
many people had spent significant
portions of their lives trying to
legitimize it but it's been a difficult
battle especially for the poor
commentators who have to call that
ridiculous handles like balls and my
nuts on broadcast
Oh names like these might be amusing but
they don't exactly scream
professionalism and can potentially be
off-putting to sponsor I'm standing here
with big dick Stacy talk to me about the
team's expectations as we go into this
tournament so the team's expectations
going in this tournament we're pretty
thick and pumped right now
going in just heads up going straight in
that nice and hard and I'll see what we
got and deliver while there are
certainly a lot of terrible handles out
there luckily there are a lot of great
ones too now iconically tied to some of
esports biggest stars fgc legend Daigo
Umehara has even discussed the
difference between his gaming persona
and his real-life identity how they have
separated and becomes seemingly
different people Connie muhannad I go to
Union game games and tonic dead burger
Crusaders to take a cut that you know a
tannish it's all about it just hasn't
undergone like any cut the human up the
game is entered for a guy risotto music
I did she buy 1000 could happen mega
will not take him another bottle on Coco
katakana no we heard up to you talk with
her about the total score British
dictate it's not unusual for gamertags
to be used as a means of expressing
regional pride and fighting games either
as Street Fighter players like PR Balrog
and a Dabashi Zangief can attest that
gonna be it just it won't go in a boxy
saying keep
moves oh where are you originally from
I'm from Debussy in Japan and even if
you aren't an eSports superstar many of
us identify with our tags it's a name we
get to choose an identity we get to
shape
maybe if we used real names in eSports
there would be fewer questionable
handles but we'd lose something to a
little bit of the flavor that makes our
scene unique and while many professional
players already use their real name or
some variation of it equally as many
incredible moments have been created by
players with tags like Baker Baker maybe
a trouble your death Mark Price the
cleanup review oh look at the class look
at the bows thank you why was that
thank you you know are you kidding me
what a flirt get it take it down and
then drop below and of course squishy
muffins switchy pounces to it
[Applause]
squishy I'd rather not say it's kind of
embarrassing really the first time we're
working together and you're gonna pull
this [__] is that okay let you scoop oh
[Music]
oh look at you hey guys it's Josh I'm
not actually dead I'm just taking some
time off to to baby on stuff hope you
guys have enjoyed the series so far
miles is gonna be taking it over be nice
to him and keep it basically